hey it's a channel takeover this is me
Joe so committee time Joe so comedy show
so comedy channel I'm gonna be taking
over from now on David's no longer gonna
have a channel and he's just gonna be in
a closet and I'm gonna be doing all of
his videos but don't forget to follow me
on Joe Jitsu Kawa because I'm gonna have
two channels so yeah come along as
requested by everybody I know on Twitter
David asked the question do you guys
want to see Joe come to a mukbang why
did we take so long I don't know because
David never want to cook for me that's
why I mean like we're like we've been
friends for at least five years but he's
totally never cooked for me except for
Thanksgiving and except for Hawaii and
except for but I actually started
stealing his content as of lately
because I made it on and I was like you
know what I've been cooking and David's
been doing Mook bongs
so why don't I just bite his idea and do
the same thing and I think that you guys
been liking it so time to do it together
right first up we have food a cocky
tempura shrimp do the presentations
amazing I don't even want to eat it
because it looks all perfect though but
I will because uh that's what I came
here to do mmm smells good this is
really good what the hell
Jen how did you do this oh my god you do
this team you see this team it's
steaming it's so good okay you know what
this tastes like
it tastes like those chips that we have
at the office so we have a bag of
Japanese potato chips it's it's kind of
like this free caca flavor well that's
what that's what's on there it's hard to
explain in American terms it just tastes
like potato chips on fit on a shrimp
mmm man you know what I'm gonna just eat
this - mmm I'm not even just saying this
cause like you're my friend but this is
probably one of the best shrimp tempura
boy I've ever had and it's like a good
ratio between batter - shrimp uh
Leighton and this one is in the form of
the letter J because they David knew
that I was coming so he customized it
for me J mmm I don't want this to end
hey David what does a mukbang mean
mukbang means eat room is eat milk
bong all like Nora bong sing room how do
you say Korean barbeque no I love this
is that shi shi shi shun owes fish she
said with tempura with a deep fried
shiso and then you put miso on top no
what is this this is like making my
heart melt right now because this is one
of my favorite dishes that my mom made
so she would get a bunch of these little
fishes make a tempura style and she
would soak it in kind of like a pones of
thing with carrots and daikon and I
rarely see this fish at restaurants or
anything like that so I'm pretty freakin
happy this is tank dude how did you do
this
are you do you eat it together okay all
right well first we'll start with the
fish head first hole hot wall man mmm
mmm oh man what da hell this is my
grocery guys out but these fish are all
preggos and they got a thousand bunch of
eggs inside the belly so it's like
surprised you're eating a lot of fish
eggs
oh it's bringing me back to elementary
school where if I get a good grade my
mom would make this for dinner for me
mmm
mmm you ever eat something and it just
knocks it head back cuz it's so good
like Mars that that's what it is here we
go
she's so leaf man David knows all the
ingredients I like I think David has
very similar taste buds to me because we
like very similar stuff Wow
frying technique is bone Appetit mmm
don't judge me guys mmm
oh this is a different style this one is
laced with the night with the foodie
cocky which is seaweed salt a sesame or
all kinds of goodness hmm man I love
food when it's like burning and mounting
my tongue and I need to go to the
hospital it's so good mmm probably eat a
thousand of these make a go extinct so
me and David we watch this documentary
on Netflix called jiro Dreams of Sushi
and that really makes sushi like you
could appreciate sushi so much more
watching that documentary and all the
work that it goes into it and all that
since there are a lot of people like
Jiro and people already ate that they
want something new and they want
something different and the his sons are
kind of like the leading I guess cooks
that are innovating and doing different
things to sushi but I still want the
traditional stuff and I still want the
stuff that's kind of like what it's
supposed to be like because I never had
it so I want to go check it out
definitely just us we take over the
whole restaurant
I heard that it only has like 10 seats
or something like that can't talk you
can't pee you can't you can't do cell
you can't do anything
you just gotta eat I hope I don't feel
like I'm sitting I'm like walking on
eggshells when I'm eating the food but
because that would suck that would suck
like you're eating something delicious
but it feels like at any given moment
someone's gonna cut you with the samurai
sword what we should get bluefin
that's just like extinct ok but where
did you get it myself
yeah but they broke it down it was just
done this morning and then we put this
sweet oh you did it like a real Japanese
chef did and you're supposed to eat
sushi with your hands ok everybody out
there eating sushi with chopsticks
something's wrong with you you need to
eat it with your hands and get a little
bit of stomach poisoning cuz that's the
real way to do it except for the stomach
poisoning stuff oh my god it's still
warm mmm David what the hell if YouTube
ever fails you always have a place in
food this is good but I don't know if
you can run a kitchen because you think
you're just uh dude this is not legit
though this is good what the hell
hmm all the wasabi hit my brain I can't
even words can't even explain how
surprised proud and like this is a good
stuff man like you need to open up a
sushi restaurant no salmon belly we have
salmon belly so this was yeah this is do
you recommend one or the other first in
which order does a sushi chef intend me
to do this five okay okay okay oh man
it's like eating a roll at polar look at
this so Rolly so nice mmm man that's
smooth man you really did yourself with
the sushi rice it's like sweet it's not
that sweet but it's it's warm and it's
damn good man what the hell is happening
oh look at this this is how this is how
elegant Japanese people with the pinky
out when you guys go to a sushi
restaurant make sure you do that and
then to tell the sushi chef that it was
delicious you go soccer ball soccer bro
I used to be a basic [ __ ] and I loved
tuna tuna tuna tuna that was the thing
that I liked the most and then I started
liking white fishes like halibut sea
bass some of the more like clean flavors
but now I really really live yellowtail
yellowtails my [ __ ] and a lot of people
like Toro which is tuna belly but me I
don't whatever it's too fatty
I like that yellowtail give me some more
of that next yellowtail Oh
Komachi this right here is just going to
be that user with lemon okay I mean let
me start with a line okay
this is my favorite fish in the whole
entire world has a lot of mercury just
kidding mmm
mmm excuse me for a moment
because my mouth just oh busted or not
in itself it's so good Matt can't
believe you learn how to do this in a
month some of these people trained for
years that just means they're slow
learners or something hmm man that's
such a good balance the belly is
definitely more rich more bodily it's so
good I think I just made up a new word
called butterly
oh dude this is so freakin crazy I can't
believe that David could cook like this
I'm just right now why does it take
people years and years to do sushi and
they still suck I don't understand I
used to work at a sushi restaurant and
some of the guys they went to Japan and
trained and all that stuff and when the
sushi came out I was like you need some
more training braddah
oh dude that's the that's the belly
belly part with the skin oh you fancy
Dan look at the way that cut is dude
that's pretty cool look at that oh man I
feel like if I touch it i'ma ruin it man
I like that it's it's perfectly like
bite flies I could just go in and then
squeeze and then my mouth is tantalized
what I want to do one day is go fishing
catch a fish grab it and just bite it
and eat it like while it's moving pour
some soy sauce on it and just keep going
that that's one of my dreams it makes me
feel like I'm a I'm a I'm a tribal man
like hunting a buffalo and then like you
know you know how they like the first
kill like you get the heart and you bite
the heart and that's what makes you like
a full-on hunter I want to do that with
fish
so spike the head maybe the tail yeah
I'll do the tail the tail looks a little
bit more edible this is the last piece
right here is that Toro Toro today this
is what the sauce and this is just
straight-up not bad either
yeah Oh what
okay so Toro is the belly of the beast
it's like the creme de la creme of sushi
hmm oh that's fresh when sushi is good
quality and fresh it's so crazy cuz it
doesn't even taste like fish it's just
that there's this texture it just melts
like it's almost like you're hot your
tongue is too hot for it and it just
melts in your mouth man dude that was so
good
joy Wow I'm just reminiscing with my
thoughts right now I'm just thinking of
all the memories that I just had and
made it was a it's one of those things
like a great vacation you know when you
come back home you just kind of rest in
your room and you you take a second to
appreciate how awesome that vacation was
that's how dinner just felt like Oh what
is that after taste umami mmm that's how
you know something is good is when you
swirl your tongue around after dinner
and then you breathe through your mouth
this is like and you could taste like
all of the different flavors that just
existed in your tooth
it's pretty good so I don't know why
people want to chew gum after a meal
because I don't care if my breath stinks
I get to enjoy what I just had for
dinner just a little bit longer
especially if like a piece of rice or
something gets stuck in your tooth and
you find it and it's like that toy at
the end of a crackerjack oh yeah that's
some good stuff man yeah hell yeah